now maybe this heading doesn't make much
sense Eve most of the questions that
we'd have a look at it's not really
relevant but there's that small few
where it is relevant and later on what
we do in verse 3 let it see it's one of
the first HSC topics near integration
it'll become a little more it also all
pieces will start to come together make
sense ok so to get at what this issue
isn't how it relates to us let's look at
this question he just got it some of
those jokes where the more you
understand that this brain says you have
10 x equals minus 1 no before we solve
it and get a general solution let's just
figure out what you'd have to do if you
solved it from north of 2 pi
so they'll relate an angle all my main
news when you're solving this the first
thing you might think is ignore the sign
that negative right 10 x equals 1 and
then you think what angle would satisfy
that okay that's the related angle so
often we call that theta so in this case
the related egg would be 45 degrees PI
on 4 okay let's go voice yourself into
rain in fine all right so so platform so
if I say feed up is PI on 4 feet of the
remaining because tan X is not positive
1 but negative 1 we know that X really
isn't platform it's actually if you want
to think about it this way or you could
graph ok because negative which
quadrants are you yeah so you have to
think about what's the related angle
equal to in each of these quadrants
okay so before
for this quadrant up here right you're
gonna have high - urinating angle and
for this one over here you're gonna get
to play - relating okay
so far so good so this is basic stuff so
far so one other is equal to let's see
PI minus PI 4 that's 3 PI and forth
sorry and 2 pi minus PI 4 is 7 powerful
okay now so far so good now if we moved
from this specific example specific
solutions we notify and try to write a
general solution for write what we know
that if this is a restriction survey
then if we either restrict the domain
okay
what's the general form once what's the
general solution in 14 starts with
AirPlay okay and then you add your
related angle okay now I hope you can
see that you can't add this related
angle okay because that you know if I
had planned for that's not gonna solve
this it's gonna salt annex what okay so
therefore it's gonna be one of these now
because either of them will do they're
both equivalent in this case you might
as well pick the smaller one okay like
you saw an auxilary angle what we want
to try and do is get smaller angles
rather bigger ones because what they
represent is a shift okay so we want to
have is less shift as little shift as
possible okay so sorry
that would be illegitimate on top but we
said we picked this angle rather than
this one because it's bed I'd smaller
okay but you can go one better than that
because don't thing in this Empire right
it's there because 10 is periodic very
PI radians okay so that is
can go forwards or backwards pi radians
and I still had the same set of
solutions right
so if I if I take this right and say
well that should be equivalent to this
angle
if I go back pi radians okay the reason
why this is better off is because what
I'm going to get here will be a cute
right it's going to be n PI minus PI
over 4
ok so this is better still it's better
than 3.4 and 7/4 and this is actually
the preferred way to write the general
solution now just keep in mind these
really are all equal this is they're all
equivalent okay but you're really ought
to write it in the best way possible
just like if you're solving something
you want to solve it in the fastest way
possible okay so in fact when it comes
to tear this related angle here
sometimes it's negative okay the domain
for this related angle is minus poem to
it inclusive weight inclusive not
inclusive because you'd land on their
own asymptotes took my logic I just okay
sure because 7 PI over 4 and 3 plan for
are both outside this domain okay
- pineapple is a better answer now the
same thing comes up if you think about
any of the other ones for instance let's
do sine x equals minus a cough so if I
were to solve this from naught to 360 my
hands are gonna be down here in
quadrants three and four right because
sine is negative so the related angle
theta in this case he is if you ignore
the sign austria's hot it's gonna be
plan six okay so you think okay well
what is the relay tangled in these
quadrants it's going to be pi plus pi +
6 or 2pi
Hispanics okay so what's that 7 pi/4 11
pi okay now again both of these are huge
angles right and we can think of a
better one remembering that rather
they're not PI here sine is periodic on
two pi radians okay so this is my
specific solution let's make it general
and I wonder which one of these do you
think would be better I'm actually gonna
take both and we'll see what happens and
it's all optimist stretch this out let's
take the general solution for 7.6 you go
Empire plus switch 7.6 okay and over
here I go in PI plus switch 11.6 okay
now if I want to shift either of these
rather than PI radians I'm going to
shift them to PI radians okay I just
want to shift this part here that's the
part with the real in England okay so
this would be equivalent to switch 7-5
6-2 pi that's the part there which is
it's really good
okay and over here I'll do the same but
I'll do it to this okay can you see
what's happening which one's going to
give you a better result this one gonna
give you a better one right because
other than six that's so close to 2 pi
you just can have a little bit left over
whereas this one is quite far away let's
actually get the answers this is going
to be plus switch that's 12 pounds six
seven minus five five on six where is
this answer here is eleven point six
minus 12 minus 6 so it's just that so
that's a better result okay so I would
go for this one this would be my
preference now you can either write that
minus sign in there okay and highlight
my related angle is negative or you can
I actually take it out and slap it there
instead of that first time okay because
they really are the same thing
I think remember the textbook actually
writes it like this it doesn't okay yeah
okay yeah good question um I've been
trying to go through the steps to try
and draw out for you the fact that this
is equivalent to this and this because
of the shift okay but once you see that
a negative related angle is going to
make more sense than an obtuse or reflex
positive angle you can go straight to
this result actually probably straight
so there is a better place to go okay
yeah you mean why do I need to know if
the pond for oh good okay okay now yeah
now here's the theme usually this is
about usually too bad okay
and this is what I was saying there's
nuances here which I'm not going to
explain until so for when we do
chemistry but you remember that I said
that the related angle right one of the
ways you can get it is just by a ticking
calculator and instead of saying theta
you just pour it here it is instead of
this you put 10 inverse okay 10 inverse
of minus 1 in this case okay
or over here in place of minus 5 point 6
or minus point 6 you just put in sine
inverse of minus 1/2 okay now for a very
important reason this is actually going
to land you on exactly the right angle
because it's designed for this situation
inverse trig was invented partly to
solve this problem which is what
automatically gives you the right answer
whereas before you know when on these
were the kinds of questions
in this trick wasn't designed for those
which is right sometimes well all the
time if you do 10 inverse of minus 1
it'll tell you an answer outside the
domain ok because this is the domain
that we're interested in but the domain
of your calculator to do interested in
is the same domain we're interested in
we just want the smallest angle possible
ok so let's plan for or - pounce 6 ok so
after you've got this example written
down and nice big grin that is what you
can say is for the related angle what I
want you to do is just use the
calculated result I want to make that
explicit because we've been trying to
encourage you not to just use their
result but actually take it into the
right domain ok but the cool thing about
this is that this is the right domain
the calculators actually think of this
specific kind of problem so you can use
it without modifications if it's
negative take it as negative okay so
when you get some of the questions and
in your answer you're gonna see this
negative led angle okay any questions